hey guys it is Tuesday you're watching
games but news and my name is Jessa
let's get into it Hannibal actor and
Duda gets me all flustered Mads
Mikkelsen has talked about what it's
like working with today Okajima on death
stranding mickelson told IGN Kajima is a
master calling him the Russian chess
grandmaster Garry Kasparov of video
games he added he's such a visionary
person working on a video game was just
something I'd never crossed before so it
was a wonderful opportunity to dive into
that world the latest death stranding
trailer revealed that Mickelson is the
antagonist of the game which will also
feature the walking dead star norman
reedus as the protagonist Pan's
Labyrinth and Pacific Rim director
Guillermo del Toro also appears to be in
the game in some capacity star wars
battlefront rogue one Scariff dlc
Scariff Scariff Scariff dlc is out today
the dlc is out now for players who owned
the season pass or who purchased the $40
ultimate edition if you don't fall into
either of those categories you can still
play the dlc when it releases publicly
on december twenty rogue one scarab has
full map set on the tropical planet
Scariff that's the name the new playable
characters are rebel leader Jenner so
and all-round bad dude director awesome
chronic whose likenesses are based on
that of the actors in the film a new
multistage mode featuring both ground
and space combat called infiltration is
also included with the expansion a new
update has arrived alongside the DLC
which introduces two new weapons and a
new star card in the form of the sonic
implode up which is a hybrid grenade
that deals damage and blind those who
are looking at it the level cap has also
been bumped up from 90 to 100 also
arriving today is the free rogue one
x-wing the our mission DLC for ps4 check
out our story on site for the full list
of changes coming through battlefront
finally The Legend of Zelda Wind Waker
to was canned by Nintendo in favor of
Twilight Princess artists turturro
takizawa explained in an interview we'd
begun the initial steps towards creating
wind waker to however demand for a more
ocarina like game was growing by the day
he added when wickety would have taken
place in a more land base setting rather
on the sea so that we could have a link
gallop across the land on a horse but
links proportions in Wind Waker weren't
very well suited for riding on horseback
he was too short and adult version of
Toon Link did not seem appropriate
either high-budget live action fantasy
movies were also huge at the time so
with all things considered we decided to
have at it and switched twilight
princess let me know what you thought of
today's stories in that comment box I
had to gain spot for our feature on the
history of the Last Guardian and over
for you again tomorrow